it's wednesday december 2nd
uncle joey's joint is brought to you by
blue chew listen i know it's been a
rough year
you're waiting for your unemployment
you're waiting for this
you know you can't do what you wanted
but i got a little secret
[__] is free you got nothing but time
let me tell you something in 2021
there's gonna be about 200 million kids
born
and they won't be able to go to school
because they're [__] [__]
unbelievable but besides that
listen [__] is free you got nothing
to do but [__] sit there and look at
your wife
it's time you tell your wife to [__]
wash that little monkey
you're gonna spit shine your helmet and
blue chew will turn your dick
into a red hot poker of [__] duck let
me tell you something
i never suffered from limp dick until
last november
after i pulled my hamstring and it's not
fun
when you want to do it and it's only
like three quarters of a way
but blue chew was there blue chew is the
first chewable
dick pill same fda approved active
ingredients
as viagra and cialis you're sitting
there going joey i'm 22.
i don't have those type of problems but
let me tell you something you might as
well take a blue chew
and go in there with three [__] sets
of nut juice
because you that she ain't gonna walk
for four days
and what what's a better business card
then i can't walk for four [__] days
you got the dick of death blue chew has
the answer
and right now you got a special offer
for uncle joey's joint listeners you
ready
grab a pen visit bluetooth.com that's
blue
b-l-u-e like the color of a face when
you finish [__] the deck
and chew.com you're going to get your
first shipment free when you're pressing
code joey
and just pay five dollars for shipping
did you hear what i said to you
you're gonna get it free and you're
gonna pay five dollars for shipping
that's it
and again that's blue like the color of
a [__] forehead
you know what i'm saying when she's
sitting there going ah
i don't know what you know what happened
the dick of death showed up that's what
happened
[__] sponsored by blue chew you're
showing up with the [__]
poker of loca you know what i'm saying
it's all over but they're shouting and
again that's blue like the color
and chew like chew blue chew dot com
use code joey i want to thank blue chew
for [__] being there after helping
america keep that dick strong
because that's what we need right now
with strong dicks in a falling [__]
economy
bluechew.com i also want to thank
one of the best companies out there
point [__] blank i don't give a [__]
what you got to say
alpha brain 100 money back guarantee if
you're not satisfied with the product
nobody does that shrewd tech sport
shroom tech immune for these tough
[__] times
you got the melatonin you got the new
mood on it
has everything you need to get your tip
top magoo
i was struggling for months i wanted a
little cycle alpha brain
and i've been throwing a little heat
lately you know what i'm saying from
time to time
you could see the old joey coming back
because i got focus
i got [__] mental focus and that's
the most important thing
with what's going on right now you can't
let your mind slip
go to honor.com and alpha brain comes in
a powder too you just put it in some
water
shake it up it's got some great [__]
flavors they got some sale
of great sale items left over from black
friday
and cyber monday but it's [__] big
dick wednesday
so go to honor.com right now and press
in church
and get 10 off your order delivered
right to your [__] house
let's get this party started give that
indian some [__] gin
oh i forgot i gotta light the [__]
candle here
for the espiritos malos
look who it is what's happening
check one two welcome to uncle joey's
[Music]
joy
hey what's happening you bad
[__] welcome
to uncle joey's joint it's wednesday
december 2nd it's [__] christmas
month
it's the countdown to [__] christmas
who's better than you
and uncle joey will be here with you
throughout the whole [__] thing
i know that listen this time of the year
it's kind of [__] hard for some
people some people just walk around like
merry christmas like merry go you know
that's great uh you know you're having a
good time you're pilot
but for some people christmas is a rough
time of the year
we'll be here this year all the way till
new year's no reason to be depressed
or [__] sad uncle joey will be here
twice a week you got the patreon
no reason to be [__] ho-hum you know
what i'm saying unless you're broke then
you reasonably whole um
but that means you're giving out some
[__] strong handshakes for christmas
handshakes like a [__] to share
for christmas
merry christmas with a deep look in your
eye no reason to be ashamed
it's one of those years where you
[__] uh
the year was a kaput you know
everybody's saying that
you know i'm looking at a lot of
comedians they're going this was that
break out here
[__] nuts this is everybody breakout
year we all got
[__] [__] on the bed but what are you
gonna do put it up on [__] instagram
this would have been my breakthrough
yeah what were you gonna do suck more
dick
who gives a [__] there's nothing you can
do about it
you can look at it and keep complaining
and other that
listen we gotta move beyond [__]
covert to the next stage
which is 2021 that's it 2020 is [__]
dead whatever the [__]
use your credit cards use them who gives
a [__] who knows where we're gonna end
up
light them on fire when mastercard calls
you
tell them to suck your dick do what i
did in 90. i just told him to suck my
dick you're not getting a dime out of me
go eat your oatmeal and come back you
know what i'm saying you ain't getting
nothing out of me [__]
the last thing we were talking about my
journey as a basketball player and how
by me quitting that [__] destroyed me
for years i had a hard
hard time with that because now i became
it became a pattern i just kept quitting
everything every time i did something
and i was bad at it i just quit at it or
if i didn't like it that gave me the
right to quit on
quit i had [__] major league
opportunities
you know uh for the last couple of weeks
i've been talking to you guys
like one of my friends i talked to now
they're all in their [__] 50s
but i forgot you guys are all in your
20s and 30s
and you're just learning to navigate
your way i through life
you know some years are in you know
school some years are working on
master's programs
but the thing that you all [__] share
is that you're all looking for the
answer
like the [__] answer when we're 20
all we want is the [__] answer that's
it
like how am i gonna get to the next
level what am i gonna do
what am i gonna do after college you got
these [__] student loans
you know for me i didn't know what the
[__] to do
i uh you know once i quit basketball
the second thing i quit that i regretted
with all my heart was high school
listen if you look down look at your
life
and look at your successes high school
was just really like a [__] country
club for you
for a couple more years it just brought
you time
you know uh to have the [__] you learned
in high school
it doesn't even apply to what you're
[__] doing today socially
or in your job but high school is one of
those things that you need to do
i loved going to high school i i loved
school it was for me it was
you know a [__] studio 54 but i quit
i quit it was it was so easy for me to
quit basketball
once i quit high school i was i was
putting together a pattern that i didn't
even know i was doing that that's what
we do
we do [__] and we don't and it's called
denial to some people
to some people it's just life you just
don't look at yourself from that [__]
realm that
i just quit high school when i quit high
school i felt really really bad about
myself i don't want you to think
i felt really shitty about myself i had
to turn off
a part of myself this there's specific
days
in my youth that i remember just feeling
really shitty about myself
that day was one that i felt shitty
about myself
today i couldn't pay my credit card
bills because i'm the type of [__]
guy i like to pay my [__] bills
the day after i got divorced like three
or four months after i got separated
i just went rogue and just refused to
pay my [__] bills
you know it was a big joke ha ha we
laughed
but i didn't pay my bills that's that's
not good
that wasn't good i quit you know
everything i was doing
i was always quitting you know i wasn't
good at that [__]
and i'll tell you what really [__]
changed me a lot
again you know when we're here and we're
all fun and games
and when i'm on [__] uh ryan
sickler's podcast
you know we're comedians
we're supposed to give light to dark
things
you know when you watch the sopranos
some of these get you know
they go to [__] uh they go to give an
intervention to
chrissy maltesante and it turns into a
[__] fight people get hit with chairs
and whatnot yes it's an exaggeration
yes it could happen but yes it's also
dark colony it's also giving light
to a dark situation what i did with the
church and all those years and my jokes
and whatever
was give light that's what comics do we
give light
to a dark situation but i never want
you to get i never want you to be wrong
on this
from those young ages because of
quitting basketball
quitting high school my [__] was dark i
overlooked it a lot in our conversations
i was a mess when i was 20 21
22. that kind of had the people around
me that took care of me i had the
burkles that took care of me in colorado
i came back to jersey in 84 and i had
good friends around me yeah there was a
drug craze going on
and everybody was going [__] nuts but
we had some
i had a support group i had something to
fall back on
you know that supported criminals
obviously
a support group of criminals you know
i'm saying that that's a great [__]
tv show support group of criminals but
i'm not picking i'm not pitching tv
shows right now
i'm just pitching my life to you guys it
was so weird that that was my support
group
was headquarters was a bar and you
talked about the [__] you were going
to do for the day
but i think what really [__] changed
me something i gave a lot of light to
him and joked around with was prison
prison and and i hate to say the word
prison
because it really didn't feel like a
prison let's just say my time away in
college
was a great time for me because
it's really funny who we don't and do
listen to
you know i have situations here at home
where
i'm not a professional boxer you know i
don't know anything about boxing
i i know i want to i know a couple
combinations i know some footwork stuff
but i don't know about boxing but i
could hit i could i know
how to hold mitts for people and a
couple
last week my daughter was taking a
yellow belt test and
kickboxing so one of the nights i came
down here with i wanted to be sharp for
the test i go you want to be sharp for
the test
she's like yeah so i brought it down to
the garage and we just kicked the mitts
a little bit now we're just giving the
combinations that they were going to
ask her it was a it was a left jab with
a with a left [__] elbow
with a right cross with right kick and
we were just practicing it over and over
and over again
you know after 15 minutes 12 minutes 15
minutes
she kind of lost interest with me and i
get it
you know why she doesn't look at me as
her karate teacher
she looks at me as her [__] dad as a
fat [__] he doesn't know what the [__]
he's talking about
little does she know i went to [__]
martial arts although she is
i know a couple things still how to
stand how to [__]
point your toes how to move your ankle
when you throw that kick to get a little
bit more leverage so you don't [__]
tear up your [__]
meniscus and your knee there's still a
couple things i know
did i get mad at her no because
i know how kids are we don't want to
learn from [__]
your father mother you want to learn
from the karate teacher
you know i could sit there with her for
two hours going over a math problem
she looks at me like i'm a [__] idiot
okay fine i lost my credibility with
my spanish lessons she failed a couple
tests because of my
spanish because uh spanish is different
but you know
the math i'm going over with her is the
same math day teacher in school
she thinks i'm a [__] jerk off and i
get it because i'm not a teacher i'm not
certified she doesn't see me at the
[__] school
again she sees me as a dad the same
thing happens to us
in life people pull us aside people
might say something to us
we got our feelings [__] hurt so 9
out of 10 people won't say nothing to
you
when i consider my friend somebody a
[__] friend
and i see that they're slipping i give
them a [__] while you know what i'm
saying it's not in my business
but after a while you got to say
something to him you got to go hey man
come here for a second
you're better than this [__] you know
you can't be doing this
even if it's something menial whatever
it's just
we're not all perfect that's the beauty
about this [__] life
but it's so funny how for years people
tried to give me advice
i didn't want advice i wanted the answer
i wanted the answer
to make a million dollars right nobody
wants advice on how we
we just we just want to make a million
dollars like that i just want to make a
million dollars i want a yacht
i want some [__] in the back dancing
with bikinis
i want to [__] an expensive penthouse
apartment
but i i don't want i don't want the
answers to how i could
make that possible i just want it and
when people can't give you that answer
you're like oh [__] it you're a [__]
bum or who the [__] are you your father
left you some money
and i learned to take advice
i took advice from a few people along
the way you know i'm saying people i
cared about but
come on man when you're [__] 20 you
take advice it goes in one and it goes
out the [__] other even quicker
because we know it all it's it's it's
not you
it's not the guy that's watching it's
[__] me too i thought i had the
[__] answers
and we don't have the [__] answer but
something really weird happened like
i had i had awakening points along the
way
you know like
did i think i was a funny guy
not like that not like when i saw gene
wild the richard pryor movie
not when i saw an eddie murphy movie
not when i saw like a [__] like a
david brenner special
when i first saw eddie murphy delirious
did i see myself as being funny like
that
not even [__] close i i
didn't even see myself in a [__]
movie i didn't see myself in any of
those [__] goddamn things
the first time somebody came up to me
and said have you considered stand-up
comedy
i was 24 [__] years old and i'm like
what what what did you just say i wasn't
too crazy about the guy either
when he first came up to me and told me
you know you got your mind on other
things like in those days
there was only two things that could
have my mind on drugs or more [__]
drugs
you know i mean i was [__] mental
[__]
and he pulled me aside like a man you
know i was still a [__] kid i was 24
going on 12.
and he pulled me aside and he's like hey
man you know i've been doing this for a
long time i don't know if
you know what i did before i sold cars
and i'm a retired entertainment director
and i'm like you're gonna hit me with
this [__] right now
do i look like i i i even have the
[__]
stand-up comedy what are you talking
about
and then it took some time and then i
did the crime
i [__] and somebody else had told me
and between the time i was waiting to
get sentenced
i used to go to a swim program in
boulder called the master swimming
program the teacher's name was jane
you had to be there at 6 00 a.m monday
wednesdays and fridays
and you'd swim your [__] ass off i
figured i'd
get the swimming shake before i went to
prison so i dedicated myself to the
master swim program
i went three times a week and the guy
who got me into it was a ups guy
that everybody was sucking his dick i
can't believe i wasn't even sucking his
dick you know those guys are just
everybody sucks
dick ups guys get that dick sucked more
than anybody you understand me
they make harvey weinstein look like a
[__] daycare that you don't get your
package until they suck their dick
you know people suck and dick for that
package i know ups
guys for years and they'll tell you
[__] horror stories
about the sex they have on their [__]
routes and there's this ups guy i was
working at hurts
rent a car and there was this ups guy i
would see him pull his car
his truck up and he would be on that
block for an hour just talking to
[__] and [__]
and then i would see him [__] this is
no lie i would see him in the back of
the truck
taking his [__] wedding band out of
his socks
and putting it back on his finger i'm
like that [__] is a savage
but as much as a savage as he was
we'd be we befriended one another you
know i would say hello to him i mean
that's the obvious thing to say
when somebody's walking into a building
you go hello
so he would walk into the building i'd
go hello we started talking one day
he did have the body of a [__] uh a
bodybuilder and i asked him
what else do you do to get in shape and
he goes number one thing is i left the
weights alone
i started swimming i go [__] my dad
start swimming
so i would ride my bike there three days
a week and one day i'm gonna walk out
he looked at me and he was and this is
like i'm a month
away from getting sentenced like i'm
waiting for the call we're going through
the process of community corrections and
whatnot
and a month away from getting [__]
from getting sentenced
you know a month maybe two away like
there was rumors there was also
rumors they might push the case back to
because of bella so i wasn't really
focusing on it and
one day he said to me he goes hey man
have you ever thought
about getting at the stand-up comedy and
i'm like what
have you ever thought of becoming a
comedian i'm like not really
i mean when people would come up to me
with with the thought of becoming a
stand-up comic
i never really i was like
stand up calmly i can't even not do coke
four nights a week i
have no self discipline the only self
discipline i have was to lift weights
and to ride a bike and to stay in shape
i was eating like an animal i was just
[__]
lifting that many weights and riding
that many bikes and i was that [__]
active
but it really was until i got locked up
i got locked up i had been ch i had been
put on check a couple times after my
mother died but not really
nobody had really checked me my my
uncle checked me in 84. we had a little
misunderstanding in los angeles and he
checked me and because of his
check i didn't talk to him for [__]
20 years
it was basically yeah we didn't talk
from 1984
to 2000 [__] nine until a couple
months before i married my wife so you
think about that
that's how sensitive i used to be if
you'd say something to me
i just wouldn't [__] talk to you
doesn't that sound familiar
when somebody says something to us that
could empower us
we actually get mad at them as human
beings that's our natural [__]
response
[__] this guy you know who the [__] does
he just say that to me even though
he didn't call me out in front of people
he didn't say nothing to me in front of
a bunch of people he didn't hit me up on
facebook and try to embarrass you
these are men these are people that
would call you like
mine in my uncle's argument was
one-on-one
what he felt about how i was living and
how i was raised
was one-on-one he was letting me know
his [__] opinion
and i took it i didn't like what he had
to say and i swore to [__] kill him
that's how [__] i was that that that
just to let you know
how [__] sensitive we are when
somebody calls us out
for us to make us better
and then another guy this guy called me
out he didn't call me out
he told me a fact he told me a fact
about myself
i'm going to tell you today and i'm also
going to tell you how that fact worked
he was my counselor in prison
and they had to do with a test or
whatever i've told the story a thousand
times but he told me that
if he had something that i wanted
he might as well give it to me because
if i
wanted that bad i could take it from
that didn't sit on my [__] moon that
didn't sit with me well
again i pulled what joey diaz did what
most
punks [__] do instead of embracing
that
the words thinking about it and going
back to him like a man
what did i do i [__] avoided the guy
and wished him [__] debt and then it
took me about two or three weeks to
realize
you know in fact he called me and
checked me again told me you got mad
because i told you the truth
and that's what [__] do when you tell
somebody the truth about their life
they get [__] man instead of saying
you know what you got a [__] point
and that wrapped up what i had been
going through all those years
see when the judge sent me to jail he
didn't send me to jail
because i kidnapped bella he knew that
was a [__] one-ring circus that was a
[__] surge
that should if any other court that
would have gotten thrown the [__] out
would you know but it was bolder they
were all he kidnapped a car and put him
in a trunk of a car it was a drug deal
when it's a drug deal all [__] bets
are off null and [__] boy
but they made a big deal about it they
wanted to call it kidnapping which it
was i'm not i'm not
disagreeing with anybody i [__] up but
when you know he told me that i had
you know i could take something from i
took it as i was going to be a thief the
rest of my [__] life no
he was telling me that if i really
wanted something
if i really really wanted something that
i could go for it
and it took me [__] six weeks
to process that six weeks it took me to
process that thought of what he said to
me
he probably said to me like the last
week of december
and i got out of that halfway uh out of
the camp
maybe mid-february the end of march
more towards the mid-february because it
was around my birthday
but it took me six weeks to process
what he had said to me and it scared me
it scared me so much that it stopped me
from doing stand-up
because what he let me know was the
answer that i was looking for
the answer that all you [__]
are looking for
is the what what you're scared of
is what the result might be
that's what you're scared of what the
result might be
what is the result gonna be if you go
and lift weights every day
not every day if you have a program and
stick to it four days a week
and maybe drink water and [__] uh
walk to the [__] grocery instead of
driving
what's the result you're gonna get after
a year or two you're gonna have a way
better physique
you're gonna be a lot stronger your
immune system is gonna be a lot better
there's so many different things if you
stick with that
[__] workout program right now
we're in a lockdown depending on where
you live what country you live i mean
you
want some type of [__] lockdown and a
lot of people are confused a lot of
people are away from their focus
i was one of those [__] people and it
took me 60 days
80 days to step out of my body
and look in and see what the [__] is
going on
what we're gonna do here we decided to
[__] move
it regressed me it made me more of a
mess
it took me the whole month of september
to [__]
get my ground up you know lift weights
eliminate some of the fears i had you
know
watch my daughter go to school thank god
for mikey klein my [__]
johnny gumbats he called me up and he
said get up off your ass
it's time to do this podcast we don't
need
[__] try [__] cities media here
to show up with 20 cameras and the
[__]
crew with covid we don't need this [__]
and here we are [__] eight weeks
later 18
[__] podcasts under our belt we're
not the best [__] podcast out there
but we're getting through that's the
most important thing we're getting
through we formed the platform for us to
communicate on
and i'm very proud you know there's not
18 people here
i'm not getting makeup shut out of me
[__] like that
but that's not what i want anyway i just
wanted a platform to talk to you guys
to let you know that you should not be
scared
of what you could become never be
[__] scared of what you could become
by trying
some people don't [__] try because
we're [__] scared
of the outcome dog i'm still doing it
with this [__] book
every day i look at this [__] book i
gotta call the agent
and tell him we gotta we're gonna have
to get a ghostwriter
because i want you to have this material
in this book
there's so many stories i want you to
read
instead of listening to i want you to
read them and look at them
and feel
because i've read them and i've looked
at them and i felt and said [__]
this is a great story to read you know
uh
i just don't have so i fall apart with a
[__] book somewhere
and i know i'm that [__] close from a
breakthrough
where i could connect everything i want
to say but for right now i can't do it
but if you look at the podcast from day
one from october 1st
to the podcast december 1st i'm getting
better and better it's just been a
[__] process
why because i stuck with it yeah i got
my [__] fears what's the fear i got
what's all fear can you have
failure if you're scared to [__] fail
shoot yourself now end it because you're
gonna fail outside something
three or four times a [__] week i
know i do
i'm not better than any of you
[__] i put my pants on one leg
at a time just like you [__] guys
but that [__] [__] he told me there
was two [__] chickens
that destroyed me like two you know when
people call you the [__] out
you know people people today call you
out for the dumbest [__] things
that aren't gonna change your life
they're just going to embarrass
you that's not why you call somebody out
you call somebody out not on youtube
you don't you call somebody out you call
them you meet them
you say listen man i've been watching
you for a long time
and you're a dear friend and i think
you're spinning your wheels in this
direction
and i think you should take this
direction and trust me five out of ten
friends
are gonna be pissed off at you for a
while maybe lugia is a friend
maybe whatever the [__] but if you're
going in there but your intentions are
right from your heart i
listen i i just can't anymore i can't go
up to people
you know the stand-ups that i've known
for a couple years that will call me
because they're stuck
and i'll tell them how i feel there's a
few people on patreon
that i have smacked around on patreon
because this is what they want from the
dear happy section
and they have come back and said hey
joey thank you
i [__] needed that but i'll just tell
them you know get up yo if you [__]
[__] ass
you really you're gonna end up sucking
dick behind a [__] alley
for subway veggie and cheese sandwiches
and this is what you need to [__] do
if you don't want to do it take your
[__] patreon and get the [__]
there's been like three or four guys and
it hasn't been in a negative way like
i've attacked them dave asked me
for the advice but in like a soft way
they wanted like soft advice
i had to give them the hard advice i had
it twisted up on them a little bit
because that's what they [__] paid me
for on patreon they don't pay me to be
nice to you on facebook
they're like listen man i'm having these
struggles what is it that i [__] need
to do
and i lay into them the same way
i lay into myself in the [__]
mornings when i'm lazy
when i'm not motivated trust me i'm
always [__] motivated
and it's not money that motivates me let
me tell you what motivates me
life being [__] happy knowing that i
did what was on that list for the day
whatever was on that [__] list for
the day i did it today
whether there's three things two things
one thing
i might do an extra thing from [__]
thursday
i might do a thing from next week
there's always things for you to [__]
do write a sentence
write a joke from the grace of god i've
been waking up a little early and trying
to write jokes
that god god-awful god-awful
god-awful i don't know what the [__]
happened to my comedy right i was never
really a comedy writer anyway
i would write down ideas take them on
stage and see what direction that
that takes me that's what i do at
vinnie's i write down notes and i think
do you know the last time i went to
venice
i actually had a really good [__]
spot last wednesday night
you know i tell you the truth my number
was my number one hardest critic
i had the best spot i ever had do you
know
i wrote six jokes i put them on a piece
of paper
and i forgot to say all six of those
[__] jokes
so do you understand what i'm trying to
say to you i'm having problems with my
[__] memory too
i still got the sheet that's on top of
my desk not two new jokes not three new
jokes
six things that i just wanted to throw
in there
and [__] you know look at me i feel
like walter mikado giving you a [__]
horoscope right now
you know not not two things that's how
bad my memory is but that's why
because i'm living in the [__] moment
i don't even need my memory no more
i just want to tell you what's what i'm
going through right now and right now
i'm feeling a lot better than what i did
[__] three months ago
or two months ago and mikey's like dog
we got to start a [__] podcast
i was not feeling it i was not feeling
like talking to people but this rapping
with you guys just rapping through
patreon
you know pushing myself to do stand-up
listen nothing in your life
i don't want to do nothing
you're like joey what are you talking
about i don't want to do nothing
if it was up to me i would get up every
day
order chinese food and get on the couch
and watch
tv that's it
you want to know the truth that that's
my perfect [__] utopia right there
is waking up maybe taking a shower
maybe eating like a [__] bowl of
golden grahams
like some nice sweet [__] cereal
right or wrong
a nice little box of captain crunch
after a joint of [__] debt
who's better than you right wouldn't
that be the [__] life just to wake up
and be able to do that
lunch time eat some [__] chinese food
some ribs
a few egg rolls maybe take a nap smoke a
joint
[__] go somewhere bah
no exercise i'm waiting for the armenian
to come get me
once i hit 600 i might do a toe touch
you know what i'm saying but i'm going
for broken that that that was my
motivation
you know when i was 20 that was my
secret motivation
if i could figure out how to just sit
around all day
and be a waste of [__] life i would
have been happy with that i would have
figured if i could if
somebody gave me if clearinghouse would
have came over here give me a check for
[__]
500 million oh i wouldn't have bought
anything
i wouldn't have bought a piece of
property i wouldn't have an investment
portfolio
i would have snorted i would have gave
somebody like
2 million just to hold for me until i
snort the rest away
whatever hospital bills i lose a foot
all the expenses of [__] just being a
coke fiend
and then i would have just got like a
trailer park somewhere
like in some bum [__] town nice white
trashy people you know the ones i like
they come out with a leonard skinner
shirt in the morning and ask you if you
have an extra coffee filter you know
those people
like i need a coffee filter who needs a
[__] coffee filter at seven in the
morning
you realize this [__] at night before
you go to bed before you set up the
[__] coffee anyway
i don't even know maybe bring up the
[__] coffee filter
i don't even know why i'm talking about
that [__]
but i think of mr blue that was his name
my counselor in [__] prison camp
was mr blue he [__]
you know i had a problem with accepting
responsibility
and we all do that's another problem
with your [__] 20s that
you know i didn't do it he didn't he
made me do it
it was his [__] idea so
it was just a pattern i had this
quitting pattern
and i had a pattern that nothing was
ever my fault
i was late because the bus was late i
was late because
the alarm clock didn't go off i was late
because mikey
took too long in the shower i was always
like there was always
no [__] responsibility there's two
things we're coming into a new year
into 2021 let me tell you something by
the damage of 2020
you're gonna have to work double the
amount in 2021.
you got two things to remember here you
could work double you could kill
yourself
you could spend your wheels but there's
two things you gotta remember for 2021
have a [__] plan have a plan for 2021
because you can't have two bad years in
a row you'll never recover from that
you'll never recover from that and
whatever plans you have and whatever
goals you have
[__] go for them and i'm not talking
about listen everybody's got the wrong
you know
i had a roommate once that told me when
you want something
put a picture of it up on the wall and
you'll get it
so what did i do i went out joe jerk off
and bought a picture of a ferrari testa
rosa
a white one i put it on my wall go out
in my driveway
see if i got a ferrari tesla rose out
there i don't even have a tester i don't
have a ferrari bicycle
i don't even have tester you know i'm
saying like nothing ever showed up
nothing ever showed up just because i
put a picture of it up on a [__] wall
so for years i would put up like
pictures of maseratis and
pictures of aruba asked me if i'd gone
to aruba
i don't even know the [__] aruba is you
know why because i didn't work towards
those [__] goals
you got to write this [__] down you got
to go you know what
i want to test the rosa what do i need
to do
to get that tester rose oh i gotta blow
15 midgets i gotta [__]
rob you know there's things you gotta do
there's gotta be
i gotta wake up every morning i gotta
put away three hundred dollars a week
i gotta you know planning is so [__]
important
and then i have to [__] mr blue
sat me down and told me that [__] that i
could do whatever i wanted to
if i put my mind to it because that's
what he was really saying to me
that's all he was trying to say to me
just in a different form
he was like if i had something that you
wanted no
just [__] break it down for me cox
it'll make me feel
like more of a thief than what i am he
broke it down for me even a little
better
he broke it down for me in the senses if
you want something
and you put your mind to something
there's no reason why you can't end up
in that neighborhood
or close [__] do it and i gotta tell
you something
he's been absolutely right
you know we don't have confidence
in who we're gonna become if we take the
path that we're supposed to take
and i was one of those people i didn't
have confidence in
in who i was going to become but i got
to tell you something
because i put my time in because i took
my beatings
because i hate dicks on stage because i
did good podcasts
and before i did because i did bad
podcasts
is the reason why we're here fighting
through this podcast right now
think about it i want you to see what
i've
done since july 15th on patreon
and since we started this podcast and
how different i look how different i'm
acting
listen i've looked at those old churches
yeah
they're fun here but they're a little
bit of sad
it's it's sad you can't see my [__]
eyes
my eyelids were always [__] purple
you know
i had like the street our [__] shirt
on all the time and looked like a
[__] bumpy
i look at those podcasts today and yeah
we had a great time doing them
it was great to do them i'm proud i got
the experience under my belt
but that's a complete different [__]
other person
that's scary when you look at something
that you did
three months ago the last podcast i did
was basically august 15th
with lee still lovely talked to him last
night nothing against lee lee's my dog
but those are two different completely
people in there
i've evolved that much since then and it
scares
the [__] out of me i'm completely
different than who i was in that in that
box on clemson street
completely different individual my
thought process
what's in my heart what i'm feeling what
i'm thinking
completely different and it was just a
short [__] time ago august 15th
i told you guys i was talking to josh
wolfe the other day and he asked me if
i'm still doing a certain bit
and i go i did it the other night and i
did it like two weeks ago the week i
bombed
but listen even with a great bit i
bombed the second week
why it's not who i am anymore
it's just not the same problem i have
the same thought process
how the joke's still funny to me yeah
they make me giggle
but it's not what i want to be talking
about and what i want to be saying
to be honest with you guys i have no i
[__]
dear what i want to be saying i'm i'm on
stage right now
i have nowhere to look i have looked you
know i've looked at what's going on
i'm an old man i'm trying to raise my
daughter i'm getting old i got to get
knee surgery
don't worry about nothing hopefully
it'll be this month
why not i'm [__] my knees been [__]
up
i've been walking around in [__] pain
why not go down there get it done
it's a three day i gotta sit on the
[__] couch
they want you walking after two or
[__] three days
why not what else am i gonna do with my
beautiful [__] price of time
we're not going on the road in january
they might lock things up until [__]
you know we we find out who the new
president is or what's going on
you know me no [__] politics no
religion i don't know nothing
so by the time all this thing gets
chased up
whatever they're going to do up in
minneapolis whatever they had to do
covered with the [__] testing i might
as well get my knee done
and maybe go back to jiu jitsu i'd go
back to kick box and go back to
something else beside [__]
just lifting weights all the time last
week i threw a couple
punches at the [__] bag i
threw a couple kicks just to loosen up
those muscles
but it's time to do something else i
want to go on a different gym
and meet different people and get out
there and talk to different
the other savages but sorry about the
knee surgery and getting you off the
topic i want to talk to you about
you know when somebody pulls you aside
and talks to you from the heart
don't take it that bad the next [__]
talking to i got
was the one that changed who the [__] i
was as a comic
that one was
hard but at the same time
i still thank him today i still include
him in my prayers
because he turned me into a comedian
with that speech that day
you know i went back to colorado
and 893 i was here for nine months
just trying to get my footing trying to
make a little extra money just to get a
little
bumper before i went to back to colorado
to go up against my ex-wife and uh i had
made my mind up that
comedy was the path i was choosing
i was like [__] it this is all i could
do is just
comedy i might as well just [__] go
for it because all i got i don't have a
rich family they don't have a [__]
fruit stand
you know this is all i [__] got
so uh i moved back to denver and i
just i went out every night i went out
as much as i could
i covered myself with comedy you know
for at that time for me it was either
doing drugs or comment
like that those were the two interests i
had you know uh
i put on like black sabbath uh
a humanizer eye and all that music
i i didn't even know that music was out
i had no idea what was going on i was so
deep
involved with [__] comedy and
drugs i that i didn't even know what the
[__] was going on in the world socially
the only thing that saved me is i had
mtv
and one day i just started saying
[__] uh
i swear to god i saw a video for
super unknown for a fellow on black days
i didn't even know what grunge was i
used to watch a little bit of mtv
whatever and i remember like them
talking about kurt cobain and
the seattle sound and i was like what
the kurt cobain
come on i grew up on the [__] beatles
now you're gonna compare this guy to
john lennon so i didn't even know what
the [__] was happening
i i had no idea what was going on in the
world of music
there was no albums there was no
turntables there was nothing
my whole [__] room was covered with
comedy videos
notebooks and drug paraphernalia
that's all i was [__] doing and uh
it was funny i was making progress in my
own little way i was
i was moving forward i was kicking ass
you know
kicking ass if i made 20
a week i was making a lot of money but
it for me at the time
it wasn't about money it was just about
getting on stage
getting the basis down and becoming a
better comic
so tuesday nights was the open mic
at the comedy works after i got fired
from the broker
that fired me up to let me start going
to the comedy works
you got to break into a scene it's kind
of tough for you young guys that are
trying to break into a comedy scene
you guys know what i'm talking about you
got to go in there you got to walk
on eggshells if you do get the
opportunity to go on stage
you better be funny and then you got to
be likable
there's so much [__] pressure because
what good is it being funny if the other
comments don't like you
if they don't think you're cool that
they're not going to give you work
so it's just a [__] grind so i knew
that for me to become
part of the comedy community i had to
start going down there on tuesday nights
you know nothing happens on the [__]
couch nothing
you could be a thousand things huh i
can't wait to be a pilot
i can't wait to be a music producer i
can't wait to be an engineer
well if you keep you're gonna wait
forever on that [__] couch
so i said [__] it let me start going
down there on tuesday nights
they had a writing class that they
offered
this guy offered a writing class uh
and then on tuesday nights and then you
all got a bite to eat
and then you went to the comedy works
and you performed what you had written
at the guy's house
i liked the guy i liked the guy i
thought he was a good guy
but as a comic
i didn't [__] like him as much i
didn't think he was that funny as a
comic
so why would i go learn how to write bad
jokes for
right like well am i gonna go learn how
to write bad jokes
this guy to be honest the guy was a
badass joke writer
he just wasn't a naturally funny guy
and naturally because of me being who
the [__] i'm being
and being a sack of [__] i'm hard headed
i didn't respect the guy
the guy every time they see me on a
tuesday he'd come over to me
and he'd [__] ask me to
come by his house on tuesday nights and
the truth of the matter was
i could probably make it to his i had a
job that i worked till till [__] six
o'clock
and it was like you know maybe uh at
that time
maybe a 40 or 50 an hour bus ride by the
time i got to the bus station and took
the ride to denver
i think they met at seven and it was
really
like for an hour or 45 minutes and they
got food ordered in or whatever
i would have never made it i didn't have
a car
you know there was just a lot of
variables for me to get there and on top
of that
i didn't think it would be beneficial to
me
so i just kept going to the open mic on
tuesdays
and i was making progress i was getting
funnier but he had a guy
you know every every one of those comics
always has the one guy
it was like cobra kai you know what i'm
saying like you know like cobra kai the
old school and the karate kid now they
have a show about
cobra kai they always have like the the
best students
he had what he thought was the best
student
so by me not going to his writing
classes
he took it in his mind but i didn't like
him i
it's not that i didn't like him is i
didn't have the [__] time i wouldn't
have made it
and like i told you on top of that i
just didn't think i'd get much from it i
was stupid
i didn't know that anyway there was a
county works contest
and the grand prize was
you went to the comedy store you
performed for mitzy shaw you got 500
bucks
and and then i i don't [__] know um
seed something
i don't [__] know well you know what
man
even with that little work study group
that they were doing for six or seven
months
i went up there if you know anything
about me then maybe three quarters
prepared
and i [__] ripped the room apart but
i wasn't clean so
they gave him the first prize and they
gave me the second prize
which i wiped my ass with my thing was i
wanted mitzi to see me i didn't give a
[__]
about getting a second [__] prize how
did i take it
my feelings weren't hurt at all i wasn't
upset
i thought i had done a better job i knew
i was funnier than the guy
but the next day they actually called me
and they said that the guy had robbed a
joke
from seinfeld so they were giving me the
first place trophy or whatever
uh they had already given him the money
and they were probably going to fly me
out to la to see mitzi shaw
i was never so [__] excited in my
life
the next tuesday i went up there and
i'll never forget
for a while i was shooting a podcast
listen
i like being comfortable if it's between
wearing a white shirt with a tie to
impress you
you go [__] yourself i don't give a [__]
about impressing people
i just want to be comfortable i just
want to feel loose so a lot of times
when it's warmer
i just wear a white v-neck t-shirt you
know what
i know you're not supposed to wear those
you're supposed to wear those under your
clothes for some people
they get offended if you will like you
got no class
for me i just want to be [__]
comfortable
so it was a nice night out it was like
an april night in colorado
i wore jeans i wore nice sneakers and i
put on one of those white t-shirts
and i walked into the comedy works i
signed my name
god knows what number i was going up i
went up there
i [__] kicked some ass you know when
i walked off the stage some people were
there
they all said hello to me they had all
heard about the contest debacle
and then as i was walking out
i saw the guy that taught the [__]
class
his name was matt woods
and he came over to me he goes do you
have a minute so i could talk to you and
i'm like yeah what's going on mr woods
he's like hey man
look at the way you show up up here he
goes half the time you [__] cancel
the other half the time you smell like
marijuana
look at the t-shirt you have on you know
he goes and i'm like whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa i go you're [__] mad
at me
because i i [__] your guy
cheated and stole a joke he goes no no
i'm not mad at you because of that
i'm mad at you because it even came to
that
i go what are you talking about he goes
man he goes without even [__] trying
you're funny and all these [__] guys
up here
he goes and that kid could write comedy
for days and he'll never be as funny as
you
off the cuff naturally but he goes look
at you
you're not taking this [__] seriously
you just think this is
you you know what is it going to change
for you if you ever considered to take
this seriously
you would be a [__] animal but you're
not gonna take it seriously
you're gonna be a joke about this all
your life guys
my [__] hands were bulging into
[__] fists
i wanted to beat this guy up so [__]
bad
because it was like a a compliment but
not really
he was telling me i was good but the
same time he was telling me i was a
piece of [__]
oh at least that's how i was taking it
and he gave me his [__] little ear
beating because if you want this
it's there for you if you want keep
doing what you're doing keep
wearing your shirts and keep not being a
[__]
uh comic keep you're gonna throw this
[__] away
and you're gonna miss an opportunity and
man
i [__] he walked away from me
and i walked towards the bus station and
i was so pissed off at him
that i was gonna walk back and beat the
[__] out of him
and i think i even walked back and he
was gone and that's when i realized
i thought this guy just saved my [__]
life
this guy between him
mr blue and me quitting [__]
basketball
this guy just [__] helped me
realize why i have to push myself in
this comedy genre
because if not i'm going to continue to
feel the same way i've been continuing
from when i was 15 like with the
basketball team
like a [__] quitter i quit the
[__] ged
you know i [__] went to prison i did
everything wrong
these two guys mr blue and matt woods
gave me the opportunity to realize
what i [__] had and
one of them real made me realize what i
had
the other guy actually lit the fuse on
the firecracker
and here we are 30 years [__] later
doing a podcast on two things
one realizing who you are
and what you could do and two not being
scared
of what you're gonna become after you go
for that move
don't look back who gives a [__] listen
people are going to get mad
people going to be happy last week i was
[__] around here and i put up hey
i went to look at a jiu jitsu school and
the next day some guy put on [__]
facebook
i can't imagine joey doing [__] jiu
jitsu that's great that's the same
people who come up to you
when you tell them you want to join a
band or you're thinking of [__]
taking a course
or you're thinking of joining a theater
group those are the same people that
stop
you from [__] you know from giving
you that dot
ah maybe [__] mike klein is right who
the [__] am i to be an organ player in a
[__] circus
you know there's always some guy that
tries to stop you from your dream
uncle joey's different for the month of
december to get you ready for 2021
i'm gonna make you [__] realize who
the [__] you are
and i want you to start thinking about
what's gonna happen to you
when you cross over that [__] realm
to be the person
or to do what you want to do whether
it's have a band
have a podcast be a plumber be an
archaeologist
be a doctor i have to use it you're
scared of [__] attacking
and you can't live your life like that
if not
why live in the great usa bay go to
[__]
communist [__] cuba and you could
they'll just look at you and go
mikey klein how tall are you 510
we're gonna make you an astronomer
you know what i'm saying because we got
enough [__] telescopes for you
to see out until or whatever i don't
[__] know
it's the joey diaz [__] uncle joey's
joint
it's december 2nd and i just want to let
you know
that's what i'm going to be doing in
december i'm going to have guests on
here
to get you ready for 2021
of not going for your [__] project
but i want you to [__] start thinking
about what's going to happen to you
after you do what you want to do but
joey i weigh 480 pounds
it's going to take me 200 [__] years
to lose the weight
but when you do lose that [__] weight
who's the person you're gonna be
it's gonna be a scary [__]
because you lost that weight
we're all scared of who we might become
don't be scared of who you might become
be scared of who the [__] you are now
and how you gonna [__] evolve
and how you're gonna deal with that
person you are now
the same way i look at those old church
episodes
from four years ago and i see an old man
that's just discombobulated on [__]
edibles and drugs and whatnot today
four years later believe it or not i
still eat my edibles
i still do my little spray from time to
time and god knows i smoke dope with
[__] eight hands
but i'm a completely different [__]
person we change
and that's the lesson this week on uncle
joey's joint
for november 30th and december the
second
wednesday before i leave i want to thank
you guys for all the support
on ozzie's boneyard without you guys i
would have never been able to do it
without my training on the church i
would have been
i wouldn't have been able to do it so
everything you do
goes towards something nothing goes the
universe will take care of you
i've been telling you this for [__]
10 years [__]
don't give up now listen that's it and
that's that
have a great week i'm happy you
[__] tuned in on a wednesday
morning
i know you got other [__] to listen to
and to watch
and that's funny whatever but here we
got no covert
and we give you great [__] advice and
that's it and that's that have a great
weekend
enjoy the patreon we got a great album
of the week coming up i don't know if
you guys know that i do that on patreon
i also do a [__] other podcast the
joey diaz project on patreon it's three
five
and ten dollars i don't give a [__] if
you subscribe but not
uncle joey's joint is free it's my gift
to you on a weekly basis
thank you very much for another fun week
and now
for a word from our sponsors
all right it's december 2nd you're bad
[__]
if you haven't paid the rent you're
standing you're probably hiding under
the couch i ain't mad at you
things are bad all over but listen they
could be worse
if you got a girlfriend you've been
[__] sitting there playing monopoly
or whatever [__] games you got doesn't
have to be this boring anymore
i know it's been rough but you know
what's free [__]
you could [__] your girlfriend to death
and nobody would care
by the time the ppp loan gets there
nobody knows nothing you know what i'm
saying
she's in the backyard anyway who gives
about [__] about that
so tell her to watch that monkey shave a
little apostrophe
on it and spit shine that dick you're
going in deep
with some blue tube joey what's blue
chew blue chew is the first
chewable dick pill same fda approved
active ingredients as viagra
and cialis this isn't some [__] you get
at a [__] corner store
from some [__] guy without a ged
bluetooth prescribed online
by licensed physicians so you don't have
to go to the doctor's office
and wait online in a pharmacy afterwards
like a [__] mooc
and the hot pharmacist knows your dick
don't work and now you're a [__]
menace to the community
because you're a [__] man with that
dick and everybody knows you know those
pharmacists
they have a [__] an oath but they
break it as soon as you walk out they
giggle
they're like look at that [__] guy
with that dick you don't need that
aggravation
and let me tell you something else about
bluetooth it ships right to your door
in a discreet package nobody knows dick
no pun intended nobody knows dick
blue tube is cheaper than a pharmacy and
you can make
you can take them any time day or night
day or night even on a full [__]
stomach
so right now i got a special offer for
the [__] uh
uncle joey's joint followers listeners
family visit bluechew.com right now
you're gonna get your first shipment
free when you're pressing code joey
you're just going to pay the fin to get
in five dollars for shipping
and again that's blue chew the color of
a [__] skin when she's laying there
after you give her that dick of [__]
godzilla
you have a sling dick like godzilla all
those poor japanese people running
around
that's why you want to take blue chew
you want women running when they see you
[__] it they might as well hang out with
harvey harvey ain't got dick for them
you got real dick because you got
bluetooth.com
pressing code joey and it's just five
dollars for shipping
i'm gonna give you your first shipment
free
when you press code joey all right no
more boredom
play with your dick look at it from all
different angles hit it with a hammer do
what you need to do
go to bluetooth.com preston joey
the joint is also brought to you by on
it
one of my personal favorites rock y you
tropics whatever the [__] nootropics i
don't know
if that looks like a [__] scientist
to you all i know is this [__] works
alpha brain is memory and focus
shroom tech shroom tech sport and
endurance tremendous products
the new mood it helps you relax at night
[__] the melatonin spray helps you
relax at night
they've got coconut almond chocolate
protein bars
listen but i can sit here for two hours
with you [__] moocs
go to honor.com right now look at the
fine line of supplements that they got
start with alpha brain money back 100
money back guarantee if you don't like
the product
you don't get that nowhere else all
right go to honor.com
you like something you see preston
church i don't give a [__] i don't give
a [__] you can't spell church just
press and chuck they don't give a [__]
do what you need to do
you're still going to get 10 off and
you're still gonna get delivered to your
house
and you're still gonna be a better
person and feel a lot better afterward
start with the alpha brain if you don't
like the pills they got a nice powder
form you put in your little [__]
canteen
your little [__] 16 ounces of water
eight ounces of water
you shake it up good you drink it you
get the same results as the pill who's
better than
on it nobody go to honey.com right now
press in church and get 10 off
delivered to your house i want to thank
blue chew
with a big dick and on it who's going to
be better than you
with a big dick and a [__] full
memory
you're not going to forget nothing
where's that [__] at i'm busting it
go to honor.com right now preston church
and go to bluechu and preston joey and
that's it and that's that
have a great weekend do what you need to
do and [__] and i'll be here monday
morning
on the countdown at christmas all right
there you go i blew out the candle i
ain't got covered
you